were you already a prankster at 11 were
you one of those kids
yeah i thought things were funny i mean
i think uh yes
i i thought there were things that were
funny to do got in trouble in school a
lot so
i guess and i hear even your kids now
well they're three they're already being
pranksters
yeah i've been so look my kids are
clearly
my wife's children right they are three
and they speak
fluent italian and they they're you know
way ahead
my wife's a genius they're brilliant
kids it is my job
to dumb them down it's my job to put
you know the actor in them a little bit
and so i i teach them
horrible things that because remember
it's only the four of us
so i just want to hear the shriek from
my wife and i know i've succeeded
so i taught him to put nutella
in their nappy and then go upstairs and
take it off and then pick it up and eat
it
and the sound you hear
who has a 15 month old some one of you
guys michael yeah both of us
both of you do okay i know parents are
very
elegant teach them this move i promise
you it's going to be good
just do it